We currently have a main view which
shows nothing, a menu view, and
an item view.
Let's say that an item has stats,
like nutrition facts, but
we only want to show them if
the user wants to see them.
Better yet, what if we want to send
a link to a friend that takes them right
to the strawberry
pudding's nutrition facts?
We can do all of this with
ember's nested routes.
Ember's nested routes are really
powerful, and make building
seemingly complex applications,
well, actually pretty easy.
When I think of a template, I think
of just a chunk of standalone HTML.
Ember templates can also be
thought of as containers.
The base container is
the application template,
and contains all other templates.
Any site-wide HTML should go in here,
like a site's header,
navigation, and footer.
The menu template is contained inside
of the application template, and
the item template also goes
inside the application template.
We want to create a nutrition
template that's contained or
nested inside of our item template.
Everything starts with a route, and
that will be item, and then the dynamic
segment, which will be the menu
item's name, and then nutrition.
How does amber know how or
where to insert the item template
into the application template,
or nutrition into item?
We'll look at that after we
generate the nutrition template.
Let's create the nutrition route, and
have it nested inside the item route.
Again, ember CLI updates the router, and
creates a route file and
a template in a new item subfolder.
Notice that nested routes
are created inside a function
that's been added as a last
argument to the containing route.
Let's add some content to
the nutrition template, and
let's add a link in the item
template to the nutrition view.
Fantastic, the app's really
starting to come together.
The application template contains item,
and item contains nutrition.
Do you see these here?
This tells ember to insert
nested templates right here.
You can do anything with this code,
though.
Move it anywhere you want,
put it inside HTML, or even delete it.
Careful when deleting them, though.
If I delete this one,
then no other templates will show up,
since they don't know
where to be nested.
So I'll return each
one to the way it was.